all right we have a segment on the
program called hate reott mail what is
hatred mail this is hatred mail
we're so all right it's wrong Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom right so I get all sorts of
horrible messages all the time from
viewers and listeners of the show we
take some of the most outrageous ones
and they are interpretive Lee read by a
professional voice-over artist this one
is about did David Pakman free innocent
blacks take a listen to this hos David
Pakman did he get our economy going
did he secure peace in the Middle East
did he destroy Isis did he get
unemployment down to a 50-year low did
he get employment to an all-time high
for Latino black and Asian Americans did
he have historic summit meetings with
Lil Kim who's David Pakman did he strike
a historic trade deal with China did he
free innocent black Americans being
unjustly held in prison did he strike
trade deals with Japan Mexico and China
who's David Pakman David Pakman Stu some
loser on u-tube Donald J Trump did all
those other things
DJ T 2020
this is actually a pretty interesting
hey Patriot male and I'd love to if I
had the opportunity to speak to this
hatred I would actually want to say what
exactly did Donald Trump do on some of
those issues like what did Donald Trump
get from his summits with Kim jong-un
what exactly did Donald Trump do to
reduce unemployment and I think what you
would very quickly find is that on some
of those accomplishments listed by the
hatred I am about as responsible as his
Donald Trump not all of them but on some
of them I think Donald Trump and I share
roughly equal responsibility for the
so-called accomplishments listed there
make sure that you make hay tree its
fry by using the coupon code hate reott
40 when you use the coupon code hey tree
at forty at join pakman.com you save 40%
and hatreds get really upset that their
hatred mail is just going nowhere in
helping to reduce support for the show
if anything it's embolden inspiring
support for the show that's how I see it
anyway